ça se passe bien non
très bien
c'est qu'à ma part les j'ai répondu
j'ai entendu des voix lors j'ai entendu
des voix quelqu'un est passé m'a demandé
si ça allait j'ai dit non et puis
personne
royal
à l'impact les grêlons fissures se pare
brise
ce chauffeur a plus de chance mais le
bruit est impressionnant
hier vers 17h30 un orage éclate au
dessus de digoin en saône et loire ce
matin reste des dégâts impressionnants
comme ce gymnase désormais à ciel ouvert
transpercé par la grêle ça va la santé
ça revient ça va vous les enfants tentez
vous la sentez tout simplement oui ça va
ça va j'ai eu un peu peur parce que là
on a eu chaud très tôt cette année
mais y'a plus de saison basse saison et
on va se retrouver avec 40 ans
ça nous pouvons les et boule de neige en
décembre sous le nez
là on est dans un stade où c'est du
matraquage l'a déjà vu déjà eu d'autres
épisodes de grêle mais à ce niveau là
c'est du jamais vu ici l'orage a éclaté
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi ces images
amateurs témoigner du déluge de grêlons
qui s'est abattue sur la région
le toit de cette société de chauffage
climatisation n'est pas encore
totalement couverts il faut faire
l'inventaire du stock qui a beaucoup
souffert comme ses chauffe eau les
produits sont sont
complètement cabossée mais là j'ai envie
de dire aujourd'hui c'est la laddh
d'accord bloqué vous pas ses paroles
mais je
ça fait cher la 1000 euros 1 mais
non deux étages et vous je vais changer
en quoi oui bref non mais je maquille
j'ai pas envie de bloquer sa part contre
parce que c'est pas terrible ok
vous vivez dans ce salon quand même un
petit peu ouais
on se retrouve tout de suite confrontées
au capharnaüm
là tu dis mais où on est tombé
où on est tombé ça ça sent pas bon quoi
ça sent pas bon il faut quand même des
groupes ouais les gens sont des gros
porcs
c'est bien d'être aurait lui-même qui
ensuite vont manifester pour le climat
enfin les pistes est une excellente idée
fait des
bons sens mathias bonsoir chef est mais
ça n'a pas l'air mais ici on entre on a
changé la ville d'avila dieu lequel at
on line et à la couleur cas là est
marron commune marron on y re on dirait
de l'huile de vidange
balala je me sens mal j'ai l'impression
j'ai des trucs qui me tombe dont le coup
mais là
j'ai peur ouais j'ai peur de ces petites
bêtes là j'avoue j'ai peur des cafards
dont le black il ya un mais trois des
gages de 6 mois à temps j'attends qu'il
passe sautée
[Musique]
arrétez
arrétez arrétez c'est un des champignons
les plus vénéneux au monde
celui d'entre vous qui pourra manger un
petit bout
de ce champignon sans mourir
prendra la bonne ok voici
voici
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous montrer
voilà sur monde tient ensuite le
principe c'est de frapper sur la main
d'envoyer la boule de chantilly en
hauteur et de rattraper dans la bouche
[Musique]
quand vous voulez
ouais en fait parce que
les choses
et avec les autres on se dit c'est une
bonne c'est pas mal comme idée
fait très attention à ta permanent
alors franchement si on était une petite
la
[Musique]
light of war et c'est nouveau alors
j'espère que ça vous a plu
gâteaux chocolats bonbons de soda fait
tu veux que je te dise un truc j'aime
pas le
moi j'aime la viande jamais nuggets eu
que ça va pas me nourrir ça la vérité je
m'appelle plein légal et le sucre c'est
vrai que tu connais c'est beau
l'émission quand tu manges issue on en
sourit on a envie de manger des bonbons
sur mon frère
et des fois on se dit y'a une bonne idée
sur le papier
tu dis tiens c'est pas mal il ya une
part non parce que les moyens je veux
pas gêner désolé et honteux
ça peut être sympa
non
mais bon voilà c'est les hiboux et si
vous voulez bien vous tourner vers
citadine vous savez nos téléspectateurs
merci nous avons salué
on vous salue à demain